the professional mindset as a practice
what is a practice anyway to quote
have a practice unquote in yoga say or
tai chi
or calligraphy is to follow a rigorous
prescribed regimen
with the intention of elevating the mind
and the spirit to a higher level
a practice implies engagement in a
ritual
a practice may be defined as the
dedicated daily exercise of commitment
will and focused attention aimed
on one level at the achievement of
mastery in a field
but on a loftier level intended to
produce a communion
with a power greater than ourselves call
it whatever you like
god mind soul self the muse
the super conscious the following
are aspects of any practice
76 a practice has a space
a practice has a space and that space is
sacred
there's a wonderful book called where
women create
it's compilation of photos of studios
and workshops
where various female artists do their
magic
the workspaces are those of potters and
weavers
quilters and dressmakers architects and
sculptors painters filmmakers editors
the book has an excellent text but you
don't need to read it
just look at these sacred spaces what
you'll see is this
order commitment
passion love intensity
beauty humility
26 artists with 26 different personal
odysseys
many no doubt include divorce heartbreak
alcoholism
you name it but every woman in this book
has in her
artistic life transcended these
impediments
and everyone has arrived at the same
space
they all serve the muse and each has
discovered in that service
her unique and authentic essence
77 a practice has a time
the monks and their saffron robes mount
the steps to the zendo
at the same hour each morning when the
abbot strikes the chime
the monks place their palms together and
sit
you and i may have to operate in a more
chaotic universe
but the object remains the same to
approach the mystery via order
commitment and passionate intention
when we convene day upon day in the same
space at the same time
a powerful energy builds up around us
this is the energy of our intention
of our dedication of our commitment
the goddess sees this energy and she
rewards it
78 a practice has an intention
when stevie wonder sits down in the
studio at the piano
he's not there to mess around stevie has
come
to work the 10 000 hour rule made famous
by malcolm gladwell and outliers
postulates that the achievement of
mastery in any field
be it brain surgery or throwing a split
finger fastball
requires approximately 10 000 hours of
practice
but the key according to mr gladwell is
that that practice be focused
it must possess intention
our intention as artists is to get
better
to go deeper to work closer and closer
to the bone
79 we come to a practice as warriors
the swordmaster stepping onto the
fighting floor
knows he will be facing powerful
opponents
not the physical adversaries whom he
will fight though those indeed serve as
stand-ins for the enemy
the real enemy is inside himself
the monk in meditation knows this so
does the yogi
so do the film editor and the video game
creator and the software writer
each day we as professionals face the
same monsters and dragons
as did perseus or bellerophon or saint
george
the swordmaster advancing into ritual
combat
has inwardly made peace with his own
extinction
he is prepared to leave everything
including his life
there on the fighting floor
brady we come to a practice in humility
we may bring intention and intensity to
our practice in fact we must
but not ego dedication
even ferocity yes but never arrogance
the space of the practice is sacred it
belongs to the goddess
we take our shoes off before we enter we
press our palms together
and we bow do you understand how the
mystery can be approached via order
81 we come to a practice as students
even the peerless swordmaster miyamoto
musashi
entered the fighting square to learn as
much as to teach
82 a practice is lifelong
the spartan king ages elias was still
fighting in armor when he was 82.
picasso was painting past 90 and henry
miller was chasing women
i'm sure picasso was too at 89.
once we turn pro we're like sharks who
have tasted blood
or renunciants who have glimpsed the
face of god
for us there is no finish line no bell
ends the bout life is the pursuit
life is the hunt when our hearts burst
then we'll go out and no sooner